I feel like I should warn you BBC I'm
here to drink wine and kick
ass I'm all out of
wine
oh okay now I'm all out of
[Music]
wine
all right bit of a confrontational
opening I'm actually not quite here to
start a fight per se but I am here
to talk about some nonsense that's been
going on now if I'm being really
optimistic this might have been
completely cleared up and my video might
be viewable again in all territories by
the time I put this thing live that
would be amazing hey it's ver in the
editing stage it is live again so
resolution went in my favor but I would
still encourage you to take a look at
this video to get a get a sense of the
kind of nonsense that goes on with
YouTube around copyright issues and also
just to let me vent cuz yeah I'm still
ticked about this even though it went my
way in the end I'm not counting on it
but even if it does happen I want this
out there as a document of a what
happened it be
honestly to have another monetized video
this week because even if my review for
the starbeast does get fully released
and is allowed to be monetized again
it's now dead in the water in the AL
algorithm so you know I need to make up
the slack now okay but let's let's talk
about what happened
so uh Sunday I believe no it was Monday
was Monday this week I released my
review for the latest Doctor Who special
the star Beast apparently I actually
still haven't gotten around to seeing
other people's reviews I've been too
busy and I don't watch other people's
reviews prior to recording my own
thoughts but apparently according to my
comments mine was was one of the more
positive ones out there or at least as
far as what is getting a lot of traction
I suspect largely because the outrage
Merchants are losing their minds and
they're very loud but overall I enjoyed
it and a little less than 24 hours after
went up it was claimed by the BBC and
blocked initially in all territories all
right let's talk about what happened
here here's the first thing that I want
to disuade anybody from thinking cuz
when I did a short saying that it had
been blocked um I saw a lot of people
immediately jump to the conclusion that
the reason it was blocked is because of
my disclaimer that I put at the front of
all my doctor whoop videos pointing out
that the news armor of the BBC is
transphobic um I'll put my usual pinned
comment down below this even though I'm
not going to do my whole Spiel on it
because if you don't know what that's
about I'm not going to fill you in here
but uh this is not what has gone on and
what I'm about to complain about because
I am going to be complaining is not a
result of that existing like it's not I
do not believe that at all for a
multitude of reasons the first being
I've had that thing up for over two
years now including on videos for newly
released episodes so no it's not that
not to mention the fact that it was BBC
Studios specifically and not BBC News or
the overarching BBC organization that
claimed it I'll get into the specifics
of the claim in a minute now there's
also something I have to correct from
what I said as well I initially in my
anger um said on Twitter that I was
certain that this was a manual claim now
to clarify that for people who don't
know when stuff gets claimed on your
video there's two ways that happens the
most common way by far is copyright Bots
just flag it and that is the one most
prone to being wrong because copyright
Bots are not human beings and amongst
other things they don't account for fair
use that's the big problem with
copyright Bots um but usually so like I
use Clips regularly in my Doctor Who
videos this is not true of all copyright
holders but what has H held true for me
with the BBC is so long as you use Clips
under 10 seconds in length that seems to
clear the copyright Bots now that's not
an absolute that's not like oh as long
as it's under 10 seconds nobody will
bother you no it just has to do with how
the BBC specifically has set up their um
parameters for the copyright Bots to
claim stuff if it's under 10 seconds
they they leave it alone generally
speaking um and that has that has worked
for me for a very long time and no there
were no Clips in this episode over 10
seconds long uh I again I'll get to what
they specifically claimed but anyway
Bots are the most common way your things
get claimed and when you first upload
something it goes through a check you
can actually put it live before the
check is completed but this video
cleared check it cleared the standard
copyright Bots looking it over
everything was fine I put it live and it
was performing very well it actually was
on track to be potentially my most
successful video of the year and this is
a year that I had a video Break 100,000
um within a month of release which has
literally never happened before so this
was on Pace to do really well and then
then it was claimed now I said there's
two ways it gets claimed the second way
is a manual claim meaning rather than a
bot picking it up somebody who either is
the copyright holder or works for the
company that holds the copyright saw it
and specifically went that is ours and a
person made a claim now I stated on
Twitter that I was very confident that
that was what happened I I no longer
believe that I'm actually pretty
positive that isn't what happened the
reason I felt that at the time and I
kind of rushed to that point was because
it had cleared the initial copyright
bots so if it cleared the Bots if it got
claimed it must have been manual right
not necessarily here's what I'm pretty
positive happened so the section that
got claimed was a section showing the
visuals some of the visuals of the
opening credits as I was praising them
and also to be clear um whether
something is fair use or not has nothing
to do with whether or not it is a
positive review so the fact that while
it is extra frustrating that I was
largely praising I had some but I was
largely praising of the episode is
irrelevant to any copyright claim so
just understand that that makes it more
frustrating but like understand that's
irrelevant but anyway they claimed that
bit but the thing was they didn't claim
it as coming from
starbeast they claimed it as coming from
the giggle which at time of recording
and hopefully at time of release
assuming I can nothing throws my entire
day off that is an episode that has not
yet been
released so they claimed that I used
footage from an episode that's not out
yet and they did it on the
credits here's what I'm pretty positive
happened I am I'm going to say 95% sure
I can't be 100% but I am as confident as
I can possibly be without directly
talking to somebody at BBC Studios who
can confirm it cuz I don't know how to
get a hold of these people you never
know how to get a hold of these people
and it's probably ill advised to try and
get in touch with them directly anyways
but that's a whole other thing
regardless I am 95% positive that what
happened was the BBC fed the Giggle and
possibly even wild blue yonder into the
copyright Bots and said hey watch out
for these and if you see footage from
these episodes that we haven't aired yet
block it and that's kind of an
understandable thing because if that
stuff were to pop up online it it most
likely would indicate that somebody
leaked stole got their hands on footage
that wasn't supposed to be released yet
this is not uncommon with something that
effectively has an embargo we can
consider that to be the case here so I
get why they are claiming some stuff
claiming from the giggle here's the
problem though since it claimed the
credits I'm pretty positive that when
they uploaded their footage from the
Giggle and said hey if you see anything
from this be sure to claim it and block
it uh they didn't take the credits out
of what they fed into the bots so the
Bots just saw me use some visuals from
the credits and as far as they were
concerned oh this is from the thing that
hasn't been released yet even though we
can now safely assume the credits are
going to be identical in every
special so I don't know if it has
happened to any other creators cuz I
don't know how many others used clips uh
from this new episode or how many
specifically brought up the credits but
I would not be shocked if this happened
to any uh others that did I can't prove
that right now and I don't I don't have
the time to check but I would not be
surprised so we have a situation where
footage was claimed from something that
I didn't pull it from I pulled it from
the episode that actually aired when
that happens you have a couple of
options you can dispute it you can edit
it and even that kind of has its own
ways to go about it or you can basically
just give up I'm not going to give up
this is my livelihood um disputing it
has its own issues and actually table
that will come back to it let's deal
with editing it first when you get a
notice of a uh of a claim they'll
actually tell you like time code what
section they're complaining about that's
how I knew it was specifically just that
bit but then they'll also say hey here's
a recommendation for what sections to
trim and you can just hit this button
we'll just trim that section and then
we'll move forward um I didn't do that
because the recommended trimmed section
was 95% of the video
not sure why that was the case if all if
all they were claiming was a few seconds
of the credits but I couldn't go with
that so that now left me with two
options I can either try and trim out
the section that is causing the problem
separately myself do it in my own
editing suite and re-upload it the
problem with that is you can't upload a
new version of an existing video that
would exist as a new video that would
start at zero views start from zero in
the algorithm no no comments would carry
over no likes no nothing would carry
over not the views none of it I would be
starting from scratch and effectively
erasing the first not quite 24 hours of
incredibly
successful um leg work that the video
made and that is a big gamble for me cuz
while that video is again at time of
recording currently blocked from
monetization um if I win in the end that
frees the monetization back up if I
delete the video I'm going to get
nothing off that and even being
kneecapped as it was that was still
going to pull in a decent chunk of money
for me so I don't want to just give up
on that I did the work I deserve to get
paid for the work I did that was fair
use we'll come back to fair use in a
second CU this is all part of how
YouTube system is very abusable
but um so that was technically an option
that was not one I was comfortable with
my other option was to edit it within
YouTube's own system because in YouTube
Studios you have the ability to do some
uh limited edits of a video that's
already in the system this is what they
have done to somewhat try and
accommodate for the fact that people
need to make alterations or revisions or
trim stuff out of videos that are
already uploaded but the don't want to
have to do what I just described which
is scrap everything and upload a whole
new version that starts from zero so I
went in and I did some minor edits and
because YouTube's back end is actually
really crap I mean like it's very
limited as a editing functionality but
beyond that once you do it it takes
forever to process that change I did
that
change I'd say by
noon uh of of yesterday at at time of
recording noon Tuesday um it didn't have
it didn't finish processing and
rechecking until I woke up this morning
I checked it at about 9:30 this morning
and it finally had the changes
in and I was about to say the claim is
still there no it's not that the claim
is still there there's actually a
slightly different claim now one that
makes even less sense so this one now is
claiming about nine seconds in which no
footage from Doctor Who at all appears
it's literally just me talking in front
of my normal background and they're
claiming it's from the giggle now this
one I have less of an explanation of how
this happened if I were to guess the
trim that I did through something off
and possibly just misaligned the chunk
uh the the time code on the chunk that
they were originally claiming and it's
just made a mess of everything I'm going
to chalk that up to YouTube just being
crap but uh that brings me to where I am
now
so I said that other than editing it
there were options to dispute or appeal
it so that brings its own problems
normally when you get this kind of thing
first step is to dispute basically to
say hey they're claiming this part of my
video and you have the opportunity to
say whatever might be relevant either
that this is my stuff it's not anybody
else's this is my original material
nobody has a right to claim it but me um
or to make a claim for fair use now
again something that came up a lot in
the comments on the short that I put out
about this a lot of people going well
isn't that against fair use yes honestly
even the 10c thing that I mentioned even
if I use Clips longer than 10 seconds
and the BBC claimed it that would also
be against fair use because I am still
doing it for the purpose of commenting
critique and so long as I am not
uploading such a sufficient part of the
episode that watching my review of it
functions as a substitute for watching
the movie then it is fair use the thing
is fair use is a defense after a claim
has been made I can't it's not a shield
it's a def it's uh it's a defense after
you've already been attacked so fair use
doesn't stop somebody from claiming your
stuff wrongly just wrongly like this has
been a thing on YouTube for a long time
fair use is a defense that I can use to
say why their claim is invalid but fair
use does not stop them from issuing the
claim in the first first place and this
is true of literally every single
copyright holder they all ignore fair
use now that's on initial claim this is
part of why I said the Bots do the
initial claim 95% of the time and then
you dispute it and you can claim fair
use which normally I do and the
copyright holder then has 30 days to
respond and
maybe maybe they will respond quickly
sometimes they do sometimes they
surprise you and they release it right
away basically confirming that oh the
Bots just swept this up they shouldn't
have sorry here you go now it's still a
problem regardless because this
especially if part of the claim involves
a
block oh that's the other thing that
shifted um when I did the edit it it
shifted so it wasn't blocked in all
territories it's now only blocked in
some territories I don't know exactly
which ones it appears to still be
blocked in the UK viewable in the US and
Canada I think still blocked in
Australia it's all over the place um but
anyways especially when a claim includes
not just a claim on your monetization or
turning your monetization off which they
can do um but they're actually blocking
the video then even if they release the
claim because you disputed it you still
you still hit a brick wall in terms of
any momentum from the algorithm so it's
still a problem regardless even though
you can get it quote unquote
undone um but as I said it can take up
to 30 days and while some of them will
surprise you and turn it around quickly
they don't have to if they feel like
being dicks or if they're understaffed
and don't have anybody dedicated to
dealing with this problem um they can
just sit on it for 30 days and for 30
days your video will
remain blocked or um otherwise
restricted until they get it sorted now
technically the video is now
remonetized um because of what I did I
didn't do a dispute I didn't appeal I'll
explain that difference in a minute but
like it can take them up to 30 days
before they start messing with you
before you know for certain that they
are going to release it and again by and
large they do it's very rare for me to
lose a dispute incredibly rare I didn't
want to do a dispute I didn't want even
the possibility that this could be
sitting in limbo for a month so if you
lose a dispute you can then escalate to
an appeal and how they actually have it
set up now and I didn't even realize
this because I haven't had a problem
with claims in a while if you feel that
you have a really strong case you can
jump directly to an appeal and skip the
dispute phase now an appeal they have to
respond to within seven days but there
is risk for the YouTuber who goes to the
level of
appeal because if I just disputed the
claim and I lost
that just means that whatever nonsense
they were pulling on that specific video
will remain the case if I
appeal and I
lose that's a strike that's a copyright
strike on my channel which at present I
have none but strikes are a much bigger
problem because multiple strikes and
your entire Channel
goes
so I have never escalated to the level
of appeal before even when I've been
fully confident that I had every right
to do what I did that it was fair use
that whatever else I've never escalated
to the level of appeal because it hasn't
been worth it to me before to risk a
strike and the other thing is you can
take it one level higher but if you want
to fight a lost appeal that means you
have to be prepared to go to court and I
can't afford to go to
court um so that and that's how these
things generally operate unless you've
got somebody backing you like unless
you've got connections with you know a
bigger organization or you've just got a
good War chest to deal with problems
almost no YouTubers take it that far
they just walk away and eat the
loss because they can't afford to go up
against these people
ironically there's a reason that things
don't usually go that far
anyway because these companies BBC
Disney Warner Brothers any of them um if
it actually went to court and they lost
like it actually went full the through
the full court process and they lost
that'd be really bad for them because it
would establish a legal precedent and it
would probably Force some major changes
going forward to how any of this is
dealt with and it would go against them
because right now it's all heavily
weighted in their favor they hold most
of the power and they don't want to risk
losing that so they don't really want it
to go to court either but they can
afford to go to court I can't but I
didn't appeal in this case
anyway partly out of spite and partly
out of the absurdity that the specific
section they claimed at this point was
just
me you don't own my face BBC and if
you're trying to claim that you do I
want a damn residual check if you're
claiming that 9 seconds of my review
video of the star Beast appears in the
giggle I want to see the forms where I
signed off on that but I know that's not
the case it's just BS and as I said in
this case it misaligning in terms of the
timing is probably a glitch on YouTube's
part not spite on the BBC's part but
it's
still
nonsense this
is this is just how this thing works and
again this wasn't malice on the part of
BBC it was most likely an oversight on
their part that when put through YouTube
broken easily abused and frequently
abused uh copyright claim system
resulted in just an absolute headache
and nightmare of a day for me well I'm
on day two now so I guess a day
plus as I said I've done an appeal and
if between when I shoot this and I edit
it I get a response back on that I'll
tack it on here but one of two things is
going to happen at this point
either uh the BBC realizes that it
messed up or that YouTube messed up on
their behalf I suppose would be more
accurate and they just let the whole
thing go and the video goes back to
normal uh it's still a problem for me as
I said because all momentum is gone in
the algorithm um
or they continue to try to claim this
and I get a strike on my channel and I
can't afford to keep fighting
it uh justice is for the money need
class if you weren't already aware you
have to be able to afford Justice
doesn't matter if the law is actually on
your
side it has not for a very long time if
it ever did all that matters is can you
afford to go to court and I cannot so
we'll see we'll see what happens but as
I said at the start even if this does
clear up in my favor I still want to
document
it cuz this is just such infuriating
nonsense and if you couldn't already
guess this does mean that when I review
the next two specials for Doctor Who and
we'll see whether or not I'm still
feeling the spicy when we start getting
to shoy goa's episodes but at the very
least the next two specials with David
Tenon in it I'm not going to use a
single lick of
footage and my videos will be the worst
for it the use of those clips is not
intended to skirt copyright it is done
to better illustrate the points which I
am discussing to give a visual
representation of the things that I am
saying and sometimes to pull specific
lines if I thought a line delivery or
the wording of something was really good
or really
bad it
enhances my work my work my review my
opinion my critique protected by fair
use and so the reviews for the next two
are going to be worse in terms of my
output I am not going to be happy with
them because I'll know they would be
better they would be enhanced by the use
of footage but I'm not going to do
it none of it not a click of footage
it's fair in the editing phase again I
might I'm feeling a little less salty
than when I recorded this but if I do it
definitely won't include the credits and
yeah I'll still have the disclaimer up
at the front end because as I said the
disclaimer is not the reason this
happened though I'm sure if the BBC is
aware of me at all which I doubt but if
they are they probably hate
that but as I said I've been doing it
for two years including in reviews of
newly released stuff so if that was
their issue they would have done it long
before this
but
regardless that's my current headache
combination of uh bureaucratic
incompetence at the BBC and
fundamentally broken systems at
YouTube joining together in a Voltron of
thanks for listening to me rant
this out if you want to uh help me live
and not have the uh the demonetization
of my videos be as damaging to me as it
is supporting me on patreon would be
great even if you can't do that
regardless drop something down in the
comments let's talk about this whatever
uh your feelings
are uh and yeah we'll we'll just try and
move forward like share subscribe also
help if you haven't already but don't
worry too much about it as frustrating
as all this is what I really want you to
remember is you are
beautiful you are valid
and you are
loved you are the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
adjourned I do need to get more
[Music]
wine time to thank some patrons and this
time I'm going to say their names as if
I'm greeting them welcoming them to a
party Robin Moore zumin Lula goddess
Salida tck the thing that goes going in
the anime r
goer the Garian Oliver B solitary
pictures rrick Bogden Melinda Walters
Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks forab
likes the poodle Robin Powell t love
Tracy scrapit angry Casper Dave Hall
Rosalyn Bennett have fun tonight and
thank you for your support I don't know
why I decided to do that this time but
I don't know I'm having
[Music]
fun